so the question was positive emotions
mediated by dopamine when you're
advancing toward something say or when
you have a cue that something good is
about to happen what is the system that
mediates positive emotion at the
satiation level yeah okay okay well
let's start with the satiation issue
that seems mostly regulated by serotonin
the opiate issue is there are other
forms of specific reward that don't seem
to be merely motivated or merely
underpinned by dopamine and the opiate
system would be one of those there's an
oxytocin system as well so there are
other biochemical systems that are
involved in more specific forms of
reward but the thing that's common among
instances that make it appear that
you're moving forward is the
dopaminergic element roughly speaking
and then one of the things that happens
if you're higher in serotonin because
you're more dominant is that you're more
satiated all the time
that's why people who are low in the
dominance hierarchy with decreased
levels of serotonin are more impulsive
and also more emotionally disregulated
they're more impulsive because hey you
take your positive thing when you can
get it and so they're more dissatisfied
they're more looking for anything that
will produce a positive outcome and then
they're also more likely to experience
diffuse negative emotion partly because
their serotonin systems are lower
indicating their tenuous status in the
dominance hierarchy meaning that
everything they do that's uncertain is
far more dangerous so this is also why
it's very difficult often when you're
trying to treat someone who's depressed
because you could say there's not much
difference between being depressed and
existing in the biochemical State that
being at the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy would produce fact they're the
same thing well then the question is are
you depressed or are you just at the
bottom of a dominance hierarchy because
those are not that like the the
symptomatology is
very very similar but the cause and the
cure are not the same you know cuz you
might be at the bottom of the dominant
turkey because you're just everything
about your life is ruined so and of
course your suffering are you depressed
so no not exactly
you just have nowhere to go